[Musik]
sieben von zehn
die gibt es ja so heftig das schmeckt
brutal probieren etwas gedacht und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video erhalte ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut mir auch meine frisur nicht ganz
so gut ich kann mich ja einmal
konzentrieren die brutalos oder geht es
wieder gut aus einigermaßen leute ich
weiß dass meine tage gab es leider keine
videos viele von euch haben sicherlich
auch finster oder auf youtube
mitbekommen ich war in warschau wir
haben dort nämlich krass klassenfahrt
die vierte staffel gedreht und in der
letzten nacht hat mir richtig gefeiert
und alle jungs mussten nicht die haare
auf einen millimeter rasieren so auch
ich deswegen sich halt kraft so aus wie
ich aussehen also soviel dazu heute gibt
es eine neue folge von echteste alle
sorten von dem gleichen produkt aus dem
supermarkt und top kommentar unter einem
der letzten videos war auf jeden fall
müllermilch das habe ich verdammt
aufgelesen und ich glaube das war sogar
fast das was ich die meisten gewünscht
haben und deswegen würde ich sagen ich
war einkaufen
du kannst ja einmal hierüber schränken
wir haben insgesamt so hier stehen jetzt
glaube ich dreizehn verschiedenen sorten
ich hätte noch drei weitere kaufen
können
da hat es sich allerdings bei allen dann
nur noch um moment rüsten ist jetzt
genau um die light-version gehandelt und
ich habe gesagt ein kommt dann ist
einfach einmal erdbeer leiten mit mir
etwas anderes mac deswegen haben wir 13
sorten mehr gab es nicht aber ich hätte
sie eigentlich gedacht es gibt nur acht
rest also es so viele sorten gibt bevor
wir anfangen wollte ich noch sagen auf
jeden fall ein cooler vorschlag
superwichtig an euch ich blende jetzt in
jedem video immer den besten vorschlag
ein
deswegen sei kreativ schreibt das was
ihr gerne in einem video hatte toyota
die kommentare was man machen soll und
wenn ihr glück habt ist denn euer
kommentar im video jetzt geht's los aber
den kanal zu aktivieren jeden tag um 19
uhr gibt's neues video und wir fangen
hier rechts anderen mutig werden von
jeder auch nur einen schluck probieren
weil sonst ist mir damals schlecht wenn
ich weiß wenn ich erkläre trinken würde
so wichtig da wir hier auf einem
feinschmecker kann man als
möchte ich nicht so eklig aus diesem aus
dieser wie nennt man das klatsche nein
das ist heute vielleicht wäre es eine
flasche stimmt ich möchte nicht so eklig
aus der flasche trinken ich habe was
ganz spezielles vorbereitet damit man
auch mal die fahrer davon sehen kann und
zwar ja gut das stelle ich dann hier
vorne hin und ich würde sagen wir
starten erzählt ich bin echt gespannt
das prinzip dieses format funktioniert
muss ich glaube ich nicht nochmal
erklären das habe ich jetzt schon so
erklärt ihr werdet es auf jeden fall
verstehen wenn das jetzt das erste video
ist was ihr davon seht und ich werde
euch auch alle anderen videos in der
beschreibung und am ende verlinken
das ist auf jeden fall sehr wichtig
damit die anderen partys auch nicht
verpasst und euch noch anschauen könnt
so wir haben hier ein ganz gut aus dann
ist das ist für das heute gern das frage
ich mich gerade ob die ja was das ist
kieber also weiß also was die alles raus
gebracht haben
ich würde echt erstaunt also bin
gespannt das ist gut dass ich hätte ich
weiß so kann ich das schon zehn von zehn
geben echt alles so langweilig doch wenn
du findest des zehnten also das war
schon verdammt
du bist jetzt eigentlich kaum vorhängen
um ja ja genau ich bin überhaupt nicht
voreingenommen die einzige sorte die ich
schon mal probiert hiervon ist zukunft
mehr habe ich noch nicht probiert weil
ich fand das früher mal so ein bisschen
eklig so diese ganzen sachen weil wir
uns in der schule standen dann immer so
offen herum und haben dann geschwunden
jemand na ja auf jeden fall gut 10 cm
das macht sich gut
es war gerade am anfang aber was soll
ich sagen weil ich merke für jeden fall
heftig kommt direkt hier vorne hin
hier steht immer das beste je das
schlechteste okay machen wir weiter mit
pistazien cocos geschmack junger also
habe ich noch nie gesehen wirklich so
eine gesunde grünes müller möchte sein
also ich bin am ende seien kein großer
chorus fällen auch so baute oder so
schmeckt mir nicht also deswegen
ich bin mal gespannt ob mich das
überzeugen kann heute eine auf euch
zehn prozent die gibt es ja so heftig
dass ich total will es mal probieren
kannst du traust normal wird es so
machen weiter haselnuss geschmack habe
ja auch noch nie gesehen also ganz
verrückt ich hab ja cookie ist
unkritisch markierung geparkt also so
müller welche ist auch so ein richtiges
käfer getränkt mehr so dass dringend die
ganzen kiffer oder schoko melden also
hier haselnuss ich bin gespannt auf
richtig gut
train allerdings nicht so gut wie diese
balten ich würd mal sagen ich gebe hier
sommer acht von zehn meiste also
schmeckt halt nach milch mit mit
haselnuss so und ich finde das ja
irgendwie so so das war noch direkt viel
überzeugender ist schwierig zu erklären
aber es kommt hier achten ich merke
jetzt schon im bauch das ist nicht so
gut wenn ich die ganze große schluck
nehmen
deswegen nehmen wir jetzt ein bisschen
weniger chocolate cookies cream
geschmack ok also leute produktnummer 4
jetzt schwenkt eigentlich nur sehr
intensiv nach schokolade so cookies und
queen merke ich da überhaupt nicht
deswegen das hat mir nicht so gefallen
kommt auf jeden fall hier zwischen wir
geben
selbst von zehn ich tue mir leid welche
ihr könnt auch super super gerne ihre
lieblingssorte wie man die kommentare
schreiben ich find die kommentare unter
solchen videos eigentlich immer am
besten weil ich sie selber lese und dann
manche schreiben auch so hell wie kannst
du das nicht mögen das schmeckt doch
absolut gut aber es sind halt im
endeffekt auch nur verschiedene
geschmäcker
trotz dann kriege ich auch sehr sehr auf
zustimmung in den kommentaren oder
instagram da heiße ich alex wie wie auch
sonst kann es manchmal supercool
da schickt mir einfach leute von euch
haben zur fotos von dem produkt was auf
dem ersten platz gelandet ist haben
selber nachgekauft probieren schreiben
so jo vor lecker so also es ist schon
sehr interessant ihren wir jetzt müller
milchprotein coco schoko geschmack also
das ist für die fitness gängern da
schmeckt man auf jeden fall das protein
ich habe gerade mein gesicht verzogen es
war so ganz kurz ein bisschen eklig was
mir ist das nicht schlecht als jedes
hier
deswegen gebe ich auch hier selbst
patienten aber das protein geschmack
kommt auf jeden fall richtig stark zu
geld
wenn man es mag gerne oder wenn man es
braucht sein körper ich bin jetzt nicht
so dass ich in einem fitnessstudio
gewichte stemmen gehe joggen oder
bisschen fußball spielen das macht mir
mehr spaß weil man muss auch sagen ich
habe schon einen kranken bizeps oder was
hier auf instagram allen gezeigt mein
foto dann wenn ich mal hier kurz ein
leute ich hab das gar nicht nötig ein
spaß okay wir machen weiter
nächstes produkt beim namen
geschmacksbild asozial ich kenne das gut
dass er sich von dem portal zwar nicht
so geil wie echte bahnen möglich aber es
ist eine echte bananen kannst du die man
selbst macht bananen mixa und milch dazu
früher war ich sogar ein bananen fan ich
hab bananen überhaupt nicht gemocht und
jetzt so viel macht da ist sich jeden
tag
weißt du was die mama sozialsten fand
mit bananen geschmack fruchtzwerge
banane bau ja man das weist er bestimmt
das riecht wirklich wie vor weist dabei
fruchtzwerge gibt's die eigentlich noch
ja das ist genauso einfach zwerge und
fruchtzwerge es soll ja die sitzung
spielen er hat du hast recht das habe
ich richtig gefeiert wird auf jeden fall
besser als das das und das echt richtig
gut 19
ja also es schmeckt ich weiß das nicht
zu sehr nach banane schmeckt also
manchmal schmeckt auf jeden fall banane
aber es ist jetzt nicht so eine bananen
explosionen weißt du also bis jetzt
platz frei neun von zehn hab ich ja
schon gesagt so jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt wir kommen als nächstes hierzu
erdbeergeschmack und danach haben wir
direkt erdbeer sami strawberry geschmack
also das ist genau die haben die neu
herausgebracht müller milch shake keine
ahnung was der unterschied zu der
normalen variante ist wir werden es
gleich erfahren und dann haben wir hier
noch müllermilch erdbeer ich sage es
noch mal leiht dazu also wahrscheinlich
30 prozent weniger kalorien fettfrei und
trotzdem voller geschmack aber nicht mal
gespannt wir standen aber erstmal mit
der normalen variante erdberg und war
das will ich auch extrem gut so leute
produkt noch mal keine ahnung da fand
ich es bananen bringen auf jeden fall
besser
das schmeckt auch gut deswegen gibt es
von mir hier acht von zehn aber leider
nicht neun von zehn ich weiß nicht ich
bin mal gespannt ob müller milch shake
er
mehr überzeugt weil so erdbeermilch an
habe ich früher schon krank gefeiert
habe ich es selber aufgetrumpft und die
haben wir die nächste acht von zehn so
machen wir weiter
müller milch shake a man sieht ja direkt
den unterschied dass hier ist auf jeden
fall deutlich dickflüssiger kannst wenn
man hier ein film siehst du das nicht
hilft ok und jetzt bin ich nur auf den
geschmack gespannt
ich möchte halt künstlich weiß es ich
möchte nicht so wie man sich so einen
milchshake der so wirklich frisch
gemacht ist mit ein bisschen milch
erdbeereis oder so also da seid ihr
damit komplett falsch so schmeckt es
einfach nicht es ist jetzt aber auch
nicht dass ich sage es schmeckt mir
nicht also es ist soeben oder zwischen
tut mir leid
sieben von zehn mehr ist da nicht drin
kann man entspannt trinken auf jeden
fall aber es hat mich jetzt nicht um so
langsam echt schon schlecht wir haben
wir noch ein zwei drei vier fünf sechs
der hälfte haben wir schon weißt du was
aber interessant werden könnte so und so
einen kaffee variante von der hinweis
milchkaffee gibt es schon
ich denke das ist das eigentlich mein
bestes geben
das riecht sehr intensiv nach erdbeer
also hier haben wir jetzt die
light-version ganz kleiner flug nur
schmeckt halt genauso wie die andere
variante dar
was hat sich der gegeben abgesehen die
hat auch schon nach 15
da kann ich nur sagen schmeckt gleich
ich merke jetzt keinen unterschied ob
das leid ist oder nicht deswegen gibt es
hier von mir auch acht von zehn
die sonne ist eigentlich gut so ja ja
ist auf jeden fall gut also für die
leute die da auch auf die figur achten
wollen und 30 prozent weniger kalorien
konsumieren möchten ist das auf jeden
fall eine gute alternative bei der bin
ich eigentlich angespannte stn
und zwar haben wir hier weltmeister
vanille ganz verrückt fünfmal 55.000
euro ach so du musst du nun machen wenn
man die auf macht meist historischen
rheingold fälle vor ich hätte wird die
jetzt auch mal die macht einfach mutter
also jeden alle mobil machen könnte
hätten zu machen es sehe eher nicht
passieren
sieht es nicht unbedingt gesund aussieht
man nicht ganz
ich bin mal gespannt weißt du wir hatten
ja noch kein produkt das ich so
getrunken habe und dann so direkt dachte
echt scheiße dort schmeckt nicht und
hier ist jetzt auch nicht so aber es ist
nicht geil das absolut nicht geil
deswegen gibt es 15 obwohl ich wirklich
weiter gerne mag also so für immer
eisdiele waldmeister eis ging auf jeden
fall klar
tabaluga eis wer kennt noch einmal einen
daumen nach oben bitte also hier fünf
und zehn jetzt haben wir noch viel sagt
und einer ganz normal villa mit schoko
vanille und danach müller milch shakes
schock und wandel geschmack das ist mir
sogar das kleine stücke hat er gesagt
kurze flüge worden aber genau das ist
die einzige die ich selber schon kenne
das habe ich mir früher manchmal gekauft
ich weiß nicht mehr wann und wieso aber
ist auf jeden fall lecker deswegen muss
ich hier sagen 19
keine zehn fünfzehn weil diese beiden
waren oft dass man direkt die ersten
beiden die waren auf jeden fall da ich
darf das video wir dazu alles hier 10
von 10
aber nein bis jetzt bekommen hier
zwischen einmal okay jetzt hat wirklich
ein kleiner schluck milch vanille aber
hier mut jetzt auch nichts das riecht
eigentlich normal milch ganz kleines
stück diesmal nur ich möchte eigentlich
normale milch mit ganz leichten wandel
ich kann der sache ist keine guten
punkte geben weil es wirklich gerade
einfach nicht mehr so geil wie ammann
die bei mir halt schon ein bisschen
mulmig ist ich war so ist trotzdem
objektiv zu beurteilen hat einfach nur
noch milch geschmeckt deswegen sechs von
zehn
okay da kein hehl mit anfreunden das
heißt es kommt hier zwischen jetzt haben
wir noch müllermilch schock und mandel
geschmack das richtige nicht gut also
leute das fordert das mal dann nach oben
abonniert den kanal auf euch ach du
scheiße 119 als das wirklich so da da
war habe ich direkt gedacht was habe ich
hier jetzt getroffen wenn ich ganz ganz
großem abstand das schlechteste
und dann haben wir jetzt zum schluss und
dann haben wir jetzt zum schluss müller
milch shake chocolate cookies cream
geschmack den hat war ja eben schon da
hier oder geschmort den habe ich schon
probiert die namen schon probiert doch
habe ich würde erst dann auch leute ich
muss sagen ich bin noch ehrlich sehr
sehr froh dass ich durch mehr könnte ich
jetzt nicht trinken auf keinen fall ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen wie gesagt
schreib mir bitte in die kommentare was
ihr euch wünscht für die nächste folge
dieses formates welche produkte sich
testen wir sehen uns dann morgen 19 uhr
wieder gibt es neues video und ich freue
mich jetzt erst mal kurz aus haut rein